we've played that as much Borderlands 3
as we're gonna get this or the launch of
the game and we just played as flack who
has some real good boys the best voice
you wanted one a hug so it's important
to understand now where flak fits into
all of the other vault hunters we've
played as Amara sane and Mo's flack
comes across as a very good solo build
for one flock has the pets that they can
summon that offer as a way to kind of
get some fire off of you so you kind of
have that companion even if you're
playing by yourself but at the same time
flocks kill trees are built in a way
that are very vertically focused as
opposed to the horizontal skill trees of
mows Amara and Zane where they have
pretty good skills kind of halfway
through their skill trees you're
encouraged to mix and match between all
three of their skill trees flock on the
other hand is built very much like the
borderlands vault hunters of series pass
where all of their best skills are at
the bottom of the tree so the best way
to get to those skills is to just focus
on one of the three trees and just keep
putting points into that one it's not
that difficult to figure out and
probably the best character to choose if
you're kind of struggling with how to
play a Borland's game for the first time
black skills are raccattack fade away
and gamma bursts which are different
from the three pets that they have that
are just summoned the entire time that
you're playing and just exist
well flock has the three active skills
that they can use whenever their
cooldown is ready that's a really
important point to make you can swap the
pets independent of the skill trees at
any time yes let's talk about the pets
they're so cute yeah the Scaggs name is
mr. Chu he's in the gamma bursts skill
tree gamma versus where you you
literally like fire a teleport out your
pet appears or like teleports in an
explosion and then as irradiated and
becomes a larger pet it seems kind of a
I don't know like I thought it was the
most essential skill that flak had
because you know in addition to being
almost an extra grenade it's really the
one that empowered out of all of them it
empowers your pet the most I would
definitely say of
all the three active skills that flak
has that is the one that seems to have
an immediate benefit from the beginning
of the game the Rack Attack and just
going invisible they have pretty good
perks but you have to go kind of a ways
down into the skill tree to get there so
it might be more beneficial to wait on
those until you have maybe eight to ten
skill points to invest into your
character you also would have to justify
why you need to go invisible because
Borderlands 3 has a really well built
that second wind state anyway so you
know your need to avoid death is it's
not unnecessary and also the cost of
being revived is not that great so I
don't know like you'd have to think
pretty hard before wanting to take an
invisibility perk with you but sorry
going back to the pets mr. Chu is
hilarious it was really hard for me to
take cutscene seriously with mr. Chu
walking around in the background like
vomiting ammunition out yeah so he just
randomly would like ammo and barf it out
at random times and like you know he'll
you can pet him and he'll like give you
hearts he's just a really hilarious
companion I would say I used the spider
ant while I was playing he would just
headbutt the ground like constantly and
flak would be like what are you what are
you doing like because he's just a
lovable idiot you just got like a drill
for an arm yeah and then the jabber
whose name is meat thief he's an
interesting one because he's sentience
so you don't get to pet him like when
you when you want to do something with
him it says touch but he likes
communicates with you in sign language
we like waves his tail at you mm-hmm
he also can carry guns which is kind of
cool and as you upgrade meat thief he
can carry better and better guns like an
SMG or a rocket launcher yeah I say the
whole point of flack is to try to again
very vertically focus investing in a
specific tree allows you to upgrade your
pet as quickly as possible but yeah
flock is very vertically focused on one
of them as opposed to the other three
which now we can talk about all four of
the bolt hunters not that we've had a
chance to play as all four of them who's
been your favorite so far
I still think that my favorite out of
all of them is Mo's just because you get
so much freedom and how iron bear is
built based on she has like two to three
different weapons in each of her skill
tree and you can mix and match all of
them
I even tried running with two
flamethrowers and it
didn't work out super well but like you
have that option you can just double up
on a bunch of stuff so I like outfitting
it with a forcefield and extra turret
from my companion to jump on to a
machine gun and either a flamethrower or
a grenade launcher for some Splash
Damage and we were able to play co-op so
I jumped on the back of iron bear mm-hmm
and you know I like had varying degrees
of success shooting at enemies it's
definitely fun to be able to ride on
your your friends next back mm-hmm
this is actually a really good point to
talk about like when Borderlands works
and doesn't work so Borderlands 3 like
in the spirit of all Borderlands is it's
super about controlled or uncontrolled
chaos and it's definitely got some very
strong potty humor and like you know if
you like the borderlands series you're
you're you're on board for both of those
things where doesn't work is you know
they throw everything against the wall
and sometimes that variety leads to like
so much crap on screen yeah like so many
guns firing I want someone of so many
effects going off like you were playing
iron bare you had two flamethrowers and
you couldn't even see what was happening
because there was just too much stuff in
front of you at any one time I would say
and in my previous time running with
Mo's and iron Barret III it was mostly
fine so I'm still not entirely sure if
it was just the area we were in or just
the fact that we were playing co-op so
there was just more powers on screen at
one time but it is definitely one of
those things John Luke and I talked
about in an earlier video that this game
is very vertically focused like you can
now slide underneath stuff you can climb
on top of stuff there's all these new
vertical movements you can like ground
pound and do stuff like that and so now
enemies come at you from multiple
directions instead of just swarming you
from one side and so you have to be more
mindful of people coming from all
directions which is cool and awesome
when you're playing so let's kind of
have to measure where you use your
powers and how you use them but when
it's co-op and there's multiple people
on-screen ID
quite realize until you and I played
together there's just so much happening
when I'm like shooting and exploding on
one side of the map and you're doing it
on the other and there's just all this
noise and light and I can't tell what
I'm doing is I have to just stare at the
mini-map yeah see where all the red dots
are so I know what I'm shooting it there
were definitely times when you had iron
bear up where I was either on top of
iron bear or shooting where I was also
just looking at the mini-map like we did
one boss fight in particular there were
so many status effects going off at one
given time that you just looked for the
red dot and you fire in the general
direction until you get hit markers
which I'm sure a lot of people enjoy and
like for some of it I did actually have
fun but at some point just playing the
coop I just had the sinking feeling that
I'm like I don't know if I want to play
Borderlands 3 with 4 people I might only
want to play it solo or with like one
other person
you were firmly a dull guy in terms of
the weapons that you picked up oh yeah I
picked up some weapons found some crazy
weapons like Atlas with tracking darts
which was super essential for crazy boss
fights because again like I couldn't see
you so I would just tag a boss and then
all my bullets would go there or like
firing around corners to get turrets the
CoV weapons are hilarious like you fire
and rather than them running out of
bullets and you need to replace the mag
you just literally pull out a squirt gun
uh-huh and start trying to cool it down
in the middle of a firefight there's
just such a variety and pleasure behind
the weapons and some of them are
completely useless which is part of what
makes the game hilarious uh-huh like
you're always afraid of leaving a gun
behind and not trying it because it
might do something ridiculous I will say
this game does a much better job at
encouraging me to loot items off of the
ground and trying new things as opposed
to previous Borderlands games where I
would just find the one thing that I
really enjoyed and just stick with it
for a good few hours to that point you
and I had very different experiences in
this build and yes you got almost over
an hour ahead of me and again this was
not a final build but I had really bad
RNG luck as I have no idea what happened
you just found a bunch of weak level
pistols and I found great shotguns and
assault rifle so I just killed
everything leveled up a bunch of times
and just went through the campaign just
super easily and I just looked over at
your screen and you were like 60 to 90
minutes behind me you were literally all
the way up in orbit in sanctuary
checking out the ship while I was still
grinding like you know killer racks
level 9 racks the the level disparity
seems a lot tougher than previous
Borderlands like that's kind of what it
made a parent so like I was level 6
trying to grind level 9 creatures and I
was constantly just running out of ammo
like I couldn't do it I actually had to
stop and go back to an earlier zone
because from 6 to 9 it was not possible
you just I mean again maybe my weapons
were just bad and that was just luck of
the draw but I just kept running out of
ammo and
there's nothing you can do I say it's
I'm hoping it was just a glitch on your
end in just a bug because if not I've
never seen that happen in a boreal hands
game before where someone just had such
terrible luck they just got stuck in the
game essentially I think the takeaway
from that was I mean maybe they have
increased the difficulty between levels
and that can be interesting if you sort
of keep you in some zones to do crazy
story side missions and boy were those
side missions really freaking crazy like
they have clearly let go of the
normalized strangeness of Borderlands 1
to increase equal and just fully embrace
the out-of-this-world tone of tales from
the borderlands in this game I'm just
gonna say it we we had a mission where
we played as we rescued a stuffed bear
who was a navigator ship played by ice-t
who we then placed in the penis region
of a robot who then ran around and
shouted all kinds of things that iced
tea which out mostly navigator
repeatedly over no idioms one of the
strangest levels I've ever played in a
video game before and I'm still trying
to figure out whether or not a
completely enjoy
I am trying not to look at your plush
codpiece like I said you got to be into
Borderlands you have to be like on board
with the potty humor his there's another
mission where we made a bunch of jabbers
horny and then yeah took care of him I
mean kill them not like yeah so across
the board now that we've had a chance to
play all of the characters and we've
seen AB as much of Borderlands as we're
gonna get for the release I don't know
like what are your final thoughts in
which character you're gonna play as
yeah I think this time around all four
of the vault hunters that you're going
to get you're not is there's no wrong
choice each one of them is built to that
you can play them solo or they can very
easily work together with someone else
and additionally they all feel unique
this time which is great even though we
are getting another siren a third siren
she doesn't feel like Maia and Lilith
she is more a close range character as
opposed to the sirens kind of support
character that they've had in the past
we aren't getting another soldier
character like all for vault hunters are
unique they are not copycats of anyone
else so no matter who you pick you're
going to be in for a ideally a fun time
and a new time that you haven't had in
bordel hands before
[Music]
you